when I go to a music festival in LA
people are naked you know everyone was
there and I'll just do my one piece like
okay I'm really exposed now and here we
are and here we are
[Music]
hey guys it's my be better but we're in
Belgium right now and we're about to
attend Tomorrowland which is one of the
biggest EDM music festivals in the whole
world
I've gone to a lot of music festivals
since I was in high school because I
really like electronic music going to
Tomorrowland has been my dream and
finally we had the opportunity to come I
am so excited to as a European I always
heard a lot of great things about it so
this is a 3d Music Festival where
everyone from around the world becomes
to party it's crazy actually I've seen
pictures where everyone's holding flags
and it's literally the whole world comes
to party together we're gonna try to
different food and drinks here and show
you guys kind of how it is and yeah
we're gonna party it's gonna be a long
weekend yeah we're probably the best
ever
[Music]
we have your own cashless currency
called pearls and festival goers can
transfer them onto their wristbands 20
euros equal about 12.5 pearls we also
got a map so we know where to go
as you can see there are 16 stages which
is crazy this is the biggest festival
I've been to they also have this
Tomorrowland app where you can see the
lineup and check who's playing we're at
which time I can even create my own
schedule by a clicks and departs and
here's what I made for today cool thing
we have a refreshment point here
their hair salon had two shots as well
as a bunch of food stands
[Music]
my type
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is our home this is where we
started this is too
i BuzzFeed this is to meet you Vegas
right here at Tomorrowland how long have
you been performing in P days I started
when I was quite a while many years
completed well I think this is the 9th
or 10th I'd still love it at the very
first time I played here it's incredible
feeling especially here in Samara
languages which is are all right they to
my friend Nikki's here hi everyone one
thing I have to warn you about us we
really have to walk a lot because there
are 16 stages and it's like a whole
village and ready yeah the vibe here is
truly amazing I've seen flags from all
around the world and is definitely
different from the festivals I've been
to in America but most importantly it's
about everyone coming together in one
place and enjoying it together
hey BuzzFeed I'm Russ frequencies and
obeying tonight that tomorrow on the
main stage how long have you been
playing it's wireless this is my fourth
year fourth year night I love it because
I get to say this activities right here
it's like those waters there's so much
and the vibe is just amazing
[Music]
okay so it's day three and it's the last
day of Tomorrowland I can't believe
we're ready that two days are you
surviving or how are you doing I think
more than three days it's not possible
but today we will do all this I think I
can still party today although I am
getting like a little tired
[Music]
Irene's already I have Irene
yesterday we actually tried to find out
one of the restaurants there because I
heard Tomorrowland is famous for having
like actually like really good
restaurants on site and apparently some
of them have like a michelin-starred but
we went to a couple restaurants there
because again the it's so far from each
other that you have to walk so much to
get to one place and we try to find at
least two of them but they were all
booked or was it over yeah so I think
today that's gonna be our goal to find
the rest time we can actually really
enough yeah early enough but the food we
had the food stands we had pasta again
and you had pizza yeah that was good
that was good yeah so here's our last
day and hopefully we survived
Pizza Pizza Pizza
oh it's a BuzzFeed this is a bit of skin
how long have you playing it smart
don't well films been like travel around
the world nice people
yeah like there is possible if you feel
that everybody these people everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go ahead thank you so much
we finally get a reservation at a
restaurant a Moscow Mule so it's really
good they're gonna have screwed up this
side
really
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was an amazing dinner I'm so glad
we got to experience this before he left
and now back to dancing
every festival holds its own special
memory for me but Tomorrowland was a
magical experience I will cherish
forever it was something I dreamed up
since high school and to finally attend
it meant so much to me three days full
of love dancing new friends from all
around the world and even getting to
meet some of my favorite DJs
I'm so thankful I got to be a part of it
I recommend it to anyone who loves music
and will definitely be back another year
Thank You Tomorrowland
[Applause]
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
your part so describe here that was my
part